uh the right i've already given you my
view about so-called cancel culture in
the last segment and why republicans are
now doing this they have no policy
they've lost everything in the last two
years house senate white house
uh joe biden is the most popular first
month president in 28 years they are
desperate
and they want to be the perpetual
unending
victims now let's take a tour
through some of the funniest cancel
culture clips and claims
from the last day or two because they
now
it's sort of like a um it's like a hyena
who sends it who smells blood the hyena
notices the gazelle is a little slow on
its feet
that right rear uh uh hoof
do gazelles have hooves i think they do
that right rear hoof
uh looks a little bit not right and so
they say
the hyenas now is our opportunity now is
our opportunity and that's what the
right
is doing congressman jim jordan is now
calling for
congressional hearings on cancel culture
he sent a letter yesterday to
congressman jerry nadler
who runs the house judiciary committee
saying that cancel culture is so
dangerous so pernicious
such an existential threat that if it
goes unchallenged
every viewpoint and idea could be
cancelled
and jim jordan wants hearings that's jim
jordan
this morning on fox and friends donald
trump jr went on a cancel culture rant
which the fox and friends hosts seemed
to love at first but then you'll hear
brian kilmeade sort of try to
give don jr the wrap up take a look at
this
there's this cancel culture trying to
cancel dr seuss now
how far are they going to take this uh i
okay there's no place that they won't go
ainsley there's no place they won't go
this week alone they canceled mr potato
head
uh you know this week alone they
cancelled the muppets
uh you know they're they're canceling dr
seuss from reading programs i mean these
are books
i literally know the cat in the hat by
heart without the book there because i
read it so many times
to my children these things are not
racist you have oreo cookie
chiming in on trans rights i mean what
is going on i have no idea it's
absolutely insane we've lost our minds
and we're encouraging it you know by
allowing it you saw
you know the mob goes after cpac because
the stage apparently had nazi symbolism
because these guys are so obsessed
with trying to create any link to that
and it looked like hyatt was doing a
good job but in 24 hours they too cave
to the woke mob
don thanks everything is cancellation
and notice that
each of those things that don jr
mentions are totally unrelated
the stage at cpac looked like a nazi
emblem
okay well that's totally separate from
reading material decisions made in
schools
and that's unrelated to the decisions
made by private
uh companies about the products they
want to put out now they
want you to think it's all part of the
same liberal plot and culture
it's a sort of gish gallup
conspiratorial thinking
you mentioned ten things it's not
totally clear if they're related
but if it sort of sounds like they are
the audience hears it and goes wow that
that's quite a list of stuff but you
have to separate it out and go through
it piece by piece
here's another clip from this morning's
fox and friends they they truly seem to
have nothing to talk about
other than this talking about more
cancer culture
hey it is march 2nd it is read across
america day
it is also dr seuss's birthday and
traditionally in our country we
celebrate read across america on his
birthday because
we all grew up reading his books and
loved them but uh biden is
there is a proclamation claiming that
this is read across america day but he
is leaving out the mention
of dr seuss because of this one county
loudoun county in virginia
and they are saying that it's
controversial
and they want to cancel dr seuss yeah
they uh the researchers surveyed 50 dr
seuss books and concluded
that the 2 240 identified human
characters
there are 45 characters of color
representing two percent of the total
human population
of the 45 characters 43 exhibited
behaviors and appearances
that align with harmful and
stereotypical orient oriental
tropes so that's brian kilmeade's kind
of
fabricated outrage voice and you know
that
you by the way when fox news is
pretending to care about
literature you know it's a fabricated
issue
since literature is not a top issue for
fox news viewers unless it plays into
some other socio-cultural
outrage that they want to generate we
know literature is not high on the list
of priorities
for fox news viewers here's another
example from a few days ago
this is from the tucker carlson
propaganda program where a lawyer
named harmeet dillon told tucker
that the left is trying to cancel women
army i appreciate you're coming on
tonight so the equality act everything
is orwell
is that is this about equality
uh it would better be named the women's
cancellation act because it looks like
cancel culture has finally come for the
female gender tucker what we're seeing
in this act is
basically a denial of science and this
is the flat earthers
taking control of the government and
using those levers of power
to elevate the rights of transgender
uh women meant people who were born as
men over the rights of biological women
and it's not just conservatives who are
concerned about this tucker so there
again is the raising of the issue of
trans women
in sports i i won't go into that in
detail now
because i've done two or three segments
about that over the last couple of weeks
if you're curious about my thoughts on
that you can find those clips but in
short
the fact that individually we can find
we can find instances
where we need to sort of think through
what makes sense in
certain sporting situations athletic
situations pretending that this is the
issue on the forefront of american
culture and and society
um is another one of these fabricated
outrage issues from the right
trump even jumping on board remember
trump brought up cancel culture
during that bizarre 90-minute speech at
cpac which trump himself even seemed
bored with
take a look at this and in particular
we reject cancer culture
so remember how this all works you and i
hopefully if you're like me you have a
diverse
uh set of news sources you're not just
paying attention to the news
but you're also reading history and and
reading philosophy and
other sorts of nonfiction and you sort
of have a broad view of what's going on
in the world you follow some
international
news etc if you only watch fox news
and watched cpac and listen to what the
former president donald trump says
you would be under the impression that
the issues plaguing
plaguing america right now are trans
women in sports
conservatives getting suspended on
twitter potato head
dr seuss and of course fighting
communism
rather than the pandemic inequality
economics the coveted relief bill
getting people vaccinated dealing with
the climate
fixing money in politics getting
everybody healthcare that's how it works
and we know it works because you go to
cpac and you interview random people
this is the stuff that the attendees are
talking about we're against socialism
and communism so we're mad about joe
biden being here
what there's no risk of communism or
socialism in the united states
so it does work and unfortunately
it's hard to even have a shot at
deprogramming someone
if you can't even get them out of an
echo chamber where these are the issues
that are reinforced as the major issues
facing the country
so it's an uphill battle it's clear as i
as i said earlier with my hyena gazelle
analogy
they smell blood they see they see the
opportunity here
to strike on this issue of cancel
culture and they plan to
strike and strike and strike to quote
the great paula white
we will have a more coverage of this on
our instagram find us
at david pakman show and find me on
instagram
david.pakman as well if you ever feel
like you just don't have enough time to
read all the books you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills each one down into an
e-book or
audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from
10 different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so
long and other things got in the way and
it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks
a month and you get the entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video